All right, let's hear from a few more people
via discord at David Pakman dotcom slash discord
going next to Nick from Brooklyn, my old stomping
grounds.
Nick from Brooklyn.
What what neighborhood are you in?
Oh, hey, I'm in Bensonhurst.
Bensonhurst.
I spent I spent a week there one night, if
you know what I mean.
I you know that could that guy could interpret
that in several ways, though.
You know, I'm talking about what's going on,
what's going on.
And I am a little curious, honestly, not necessarily
anything more.
So just your opinion on kind of the future
of the country.
And I notice a lot of people, you know, a
lot of people on the Republican side, they
see they seem to just see the world in a different
way and an aspect that like when we look when
we look at things with this election, you
know, we seem to see things as very obvious
is like, well, very obviously there isn't
data to support certain things, like all these
fraudulent claims, all these that, you know,
nothing can be substantiated.
Yeah, a lot of times when I when I see or
like when I discuss, like with my parents
or when I see a lot of people on the Republican
side, it seems that their interpretation of
the world is like so far removed from the
reality that it's kind of I'm kind of curious
to see how the left can bring over these people
that see the world so differently.
Yeah, if it's if they aren't even willing
to accept anything different in the first
place, this is a huge issue.
And obviously.
Right, there's a this is a particularly acute
problem right now because of Trump ism and
all sorts of wild claims.
Nothing is ever too crazy for the Trump to
defend.
But this is also just a bigger issue in the
country.
So big.
I spent some time, for example, in rural northern
Indiana a couple of years ago, and spending
time there made me understand, like, of course,
they voted for Trump.
All there is is evangelical churches.
So your entire socializing is happening in
evangelical churches where abortion is this
major issue.
One of the few things there is to do is to
shoot guns.
So it's like, of course, they're not going
to vote for somebody like Joe Biden, whether
or not they think Joe Biden's a socialist,
like if that's your environment for your first
18 years, obviously you're voting for a Republican
when you turn 18.
Whether or not they can credibly claim to
be pro-life or not, I don't know what to do
about that.
This is just a bigger issue, period.
And we have to think about the deprogramming
of tens of millions of people from cult like
beliefs.
They're going to be exactly about it.
Yeah, I feel like, you know, as many as many
issues and policies we can put forth, you
know, try to better the world around us because
it's one thing when it's just like, you know,
we we have like the two parties to have like
or we have several.
But, you know, generally bipartisan, you know,
for people to express different beliefs and
thoughts.
But it seems more so it's not just an expression
of different thought.
It seems like some are, you know, a lot more.
But I'm trying to think of what the term would
be for this.
These are cultural issues more than they are
policy.
Yeah, exactly.
So I'm just kind of curious, not necessarily
that you'd have a complete answer to it, but
what do you think would be a good way we can
at least attempt to move the culture I'm in
one away thing would be if we could on average
get everybody one additional year of education,
it would actually make an electoral difference.
And what I mean by that is you take all the
people who who dropped out of school after
middle school to at least go one year to high
school.
Everybody who never went to college take a
year of like if you just up to the average
education by a year, which is a lot like that's
when you have a country of three hundred and
thirty million to increase the average schooling
by one year is it's a crazy undertaking that
alone, I think because of knowing the relationship
between education and how people vote, that
would be huge in and of itself.
So I do think education is a big part of it,
but there are cultural aspects to it that
that are huge.
It's a it's a big topic.
I wish I had the answers yet.
I'm not expecting you to.
I just I'm just very curious to see what your
perspective would be and how maybe a cultural
shift could occur in the first place just
because it's still so surprising to me, like,
you know, seeing just so much of the country
believe in such a cult like behavior, cultural
shifts are very slow.
There's no the ways that you get fast.
Cultural shifts are usually because of a dictator.
And so we don't that's that.
We don't want that it we have to accept that
it's going to be a longer process.
Yeah, fair enough.
And final final thing, do you also feel that
because of coming into the country, that it's
because I feel like, yes, cultural shifts
do happen slowly, but this has been or maybe
these are just all people been in hiding?
Or maybe I was there, but I don't think I
Francie's really brought out a lot in the
culture that we haven't seen before.
Exactly.
I don't think Trump created these people.
I think he gave them a place to to go public
and coalesce.
I think if that listen, my friend, I appreciate
the call.
I want to get to a couple of other people,
but let's hope to speak again.
Absolutely.
Absolutely good.
All right.
Excellent.